I want to ask you a further question on
this by the way this is pretty much the
last example like a min visitors
scenarios where you now know all of the
scenarios where you need to divide up
into different integrals and either
combine them or just treat them
separately maybe add a pass for a minus
sign I have a question for you seem to
some this set up here we didn't find
this point a place intersection because
we only need the X values but the point
is essentially actually very easy to
find what are they just look at the look
at the hunter line it's one line 104
right because they both they were play
on this line okay y equals x all right
now one of the reasons why i picked up
this example is because what
everything's positive everything is easy
to deal with so it's quite clear what's
going on okay but imagine i took this
whole situation right and instead of
this line in this line if i took both
and i move them both down like say
somewhere big aqui like say maybe two
units okay if i move these down two
units let's do it really simple drawing
of what this will look like okay in fact
a cheat way you can do this is to draw
the same lines but leave off the
horizontal axis and then just move it up
two units okay you're going to get
something like this right yeah this is
me down and then we're getting something
like that's gonna be about what's below
something like that okay now this is
Messier right this is a little more
interesting because now if I think about
for instance this first integral here
this one over here okay if I'm still
interested in finding the area between
the two curves ok so in other words this
spot in here okay when I think about
that first integral this is going to be
a little Messier right watch what's
going to open my evaluate this integral
I'm not going to get a trapezium em away
what am I going to get I know I'm going
to get two triangles aren't I like I'm
going to get this guy yeah and this guy
that's an it gross usually to handle
this area right I would say over Cape
consider that one Simon by your side of
the front then consider this one and you
can add those two together right the
same thing will happen when I consider
the parabola watch what happens I'm
going together at everything sorry which
they were trying if I go from one to
four yeah if you're evaluating wonderful
isn't it those to try yeah I'm
considering an area that's balanced in
the x axis right so I start at one and
all the way here going up to the x axis
everything's negative right all these
negative areas and then ice cross over
here I'm still grounded to the x axis so
now all these areas of positive is that
okay imagine the again maybe this will
help again think about those rectangles
that I'm actually adding up these guys
right there all these vertical things
okay so i'm pretty sure i'll end up with
these two these two greek language okay
what area will I get when I evaluate the
parabola from one school hmm you like
the
ariel i'm still going to get well if
this is going to get the complicated
right so there's one and there's four
right you can see for a large part of it
I'm going to get a part that again is
underneath the axis do you see that
that's the part that's underneath the
axis and then it crosses over and you'll
get this part here yeah this looks like
a mess doesn't it this looks like my
brain hurts like even look in my diagram
it looks pretty messy okay um where is
the area that I'm interested it like its
kind of this one and kind of that one
how does it all work okay now here's my
question to you right how do I get from
this diagram like what transformation
did I apply to get from this diagram
through that one what did I do I just
moved downwards I just translated okay
so what did you into issues say about
how this area should be related to that
area it should be the same like I just
taken the same area and I've moved it to
a different spot right do you agree with
that okay here's the theme right it is
exactly the same because it is the same
area and it's really easy to see how
they're gonna be identical without
messing about with any of this positive
or negative business okay watch
carefully what integrals am I going to
do right I'm still going to be
integrating here's my area from one to
four okay now what's the UM what is this
higher function what is its new new
equation it's not y equals x is x minus
minus two ok so I'm engineering from one
to four my first interview will be X
minus 2 now what about this guy what is
its equation x it's going to be that one
right x minus 2r squared but I've also
moved it down to okay now therefore my
second intagram will be take away all
right get ready lots of brackets okay
i'll put some i'll put some curly braces
it just for fun okay x minus 2 or square
all right minus 2 and then square back
into print shop now look look really
carefully right without dealing with any
of this positive or negative business
okay can you see
from one to four you're subtracting
there's a minus 2 there because of
course meters down but there's another
minus 2 right there this is a bit a
little bit like we were evaluating the
primitive and no matter what constant
you put there right I could take it down
200 units if you like and you'll have a
minus 200 there and a minus 200 there
okay and everything would be negative
but when you take the difference they
will exactly cancel see you know so
you're going to end up with that minus 2
and that mine is to cancelling which
leaves you back with this which is the
original integral we've worked out right
that's still going to be fingers crossed
foreign half units squared okay yeah how
do you see that's very lucky I didn't
give us that and that was just yeah sure
okay so here's his 10 around where I
would say to you right um remember how
this is how I was trying to point up for
it and put the glides render if you've
got an area that's between two curves no
matter where the curves are all above
the axis kind of halfway between or even
everything below the axis everything
being negative okay here's actually the
genius thing about integrals covering
negatives as areas right I can still
take the difference between two
negatives and they'll still be positive
right the area you get at the end will
still be a positive number okay so all
you need to know is which one is on top
and which one is below that's all you
need and then you take the difference
okay yes one of those situations where
don't know um it's one of the situations
where if you use a diagram well a
diagram is a tool right and just like
any tool if you use a tool poorly just
like using integration poorly it will
send you down the garden path or
chocolate leg off okay so yeah and
that's part of why I was trying to I'll
try to show you how messy it gets but
the fact that integration just sort of
takes care of this is actually the
tremendous advantage it was kind of a
pest before that like boy the access I
don't want that to be negative that's
really annoying I've just like a minus
sign in front but actually it's great
that it takes into account natives and
it doesn't break a sweat it'll get the
same area where ever that area is